leave
Toby if seabirds solo project is called
and the golden choir so far it's been
confined to a studio in Berlin but the
musician and producer is now visiting
the Netherlands to perform three gigs at
the euro sonic Nordis log festival with
a whole choir in a suitcase the 38 year
old is travelling on his own accompanied
in his live shows by pre-recorded
instruments and voices all on vinyl
this is fully design it's an analog
process my analog instruments and
records where lots of different
seibert's have been recorded so I
suppose you could say I'm like the
choirmaster onstage conducting myself
speed limit museums along with his vinyl
Toby SD bed uses some unusual
instruments in his one-man show
including a hammered dulcimer
he hopes it shows that the Euro sonic
festival in corning and will raise his
profile around Europe it's a showcase
event that helps bands get signed or
booked for the festival season but three
shows are a lot of work for Tobias he
has to dash between venues and he has
only 15 minutes for set up and
soundcheck
but even when the pressures on he
handles his records with utmost care
let's ease like what's the court there
oh honey mom this is the big choir
that's also in the name it's on the
record it's in the room it's in the
audience no I really need to concentrate
well he quotes wats up in a record also
supplies to drums for his one-man band Z
but then adds live vocals and plays a
harmonium industry insiders that the
festival know this kind of an event can
really make a career you need to do 10
you today we want to know what's new
because you need to surprise your
audience all the time and that's one
thing which is going or plus the
gathering of so many European colleagues
is key
after years of polishing his sound in
the studio till bsd but released his
debut album another half life in 2015
now he's enjoying playing live and
meeting his audience the Marquis momento
de nada I love that moment when the
needle drives and i love the crackle you
get with vinyl when you're here in the
room you can hear it the whole time it's
a bit like we're listening to my records
together with the audience just that now
and then i'll sing along or play an
instrument
the pierced water
and the golden choir rounds off the day
at the euro sonic notice lug with a
rousing finale to be a seaport has three
shows and numerous interviews and
business meetings behind him so was it a
good experience it was very friendly i
feel i was given red carpet treatment I
know what it's like there's a moment
when everyone gets it and they close
their eyes this sense of community is
what makes the choir and it happened
again today his trip to the Netherlands
was a resounding success as soon as Toby
as if at left the stage he was offered
more gigs his album has just been
released in the Benelux countries